Nos piden representar la desigualdad,
"y" mayor que 5 en la recta numérica
y en el plano coordenado.
Hagamos primero en la recta numérica.
Dibujemos entonces nuestra recta numérica,
aquí tenemos la recta numérica
ubicamos aquí el 0,
hacia acá estarán los negativos
aunque más bien nos vamos a enfocan en los positivos porque nos están pidiendo "y" mayor que 5
ubiquemos cinco, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5
aquí tenemos 5,
chequemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7
y así sucesivamente los valores mayores que 5
está es la recta "y",
estamos llamando "y" a esta recta numérica,
y queremos los valores mayores que 5 es decir,
no queremos incluir al 5
si fuera "y" mayor igual a 5,
incluiremos al 5
pero queremos mayores que 5 así es que
marcamos eso con un círculo abierto
con un círculo abierto estamos indicando
que no estamos incluyendo el 5
y hacia la derecha
estarían los números mayores que 5,
si nos pidieran mayor igual a 5, llenaríamos este círculo, para indicar que estamos incluyendo el 5.
Representemos ahora la desigualdad
en el plano coordenado
dibujemos, el plano coordenado,
aquí tenemos el eje vertical, este eje vertical es el eje "y", de acuerdo a la convención usual,
mientras que el eje horizontal, es el eje "x"
anotenemos algunos valores para "y"
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
ahí tenemos 5, 6, 7
y así seguiría
para valores cada vez mayores
y queremos "y" mayor que 5
no va a ser mayor o igual a 5
por lo cual,
no vamos a incluir "y" igual a 5
por lo cual la recta "y" igual a 5,
la dibujaremos con una línea discontinua,
esto nos muestra que no estamos incluyendo
"y" igual a 5
pero sí queremos incluir, todos los valores
que son mayores que 5
para esto, sombrearemos...
vamos a sombrear esta zona que representa la región
donde los valores de "y",
son mayores que 5
si hubiera sido mayor o igual a 5,
incluiríamos una línea continua aquí,
en esta región que hemos dibujado
no importa
cuál es el valor de "x" que tomemos ,
"y" va a ser mayor que 5.